(Rhythmic drumming)
Welcome to Africa.
We are a continent
that is rich in diversity.
We have diverse resources.
In Botswana, you can find diamonds.
In DR Congo, there’s cobalt.
And in Ghana, you find gold.
And then there's the food.
Africans have found
countless ways to prepare rice,
from the jollof in the west
to the pilau in the east.
But for me,
our most fascinating
diversity is our dance.
I am passionate about African dance
because I'm a dancer and I'm African.
But I also believe
that dance is important,
and through it we can learn
so much about our history
and where we come from.
If the African culture was a tree,
then I think dance would be its flowers.
If you look at the African dance of today,
you find that its core foundation
is traditional dance,
and these are dances that were created
with a specific purpose,
for a ceremony or a celebration.
It could be for war,
for coming of age or even to bring rain.
But what's really interesting
with traditional dance
is that through it you can almost paint
this visual map of migration.
And so through the movement of a dance,
you can trace the movement of people.
And so even though Africa is the most
diverse continent in the world,
we're also much more
connected than we think.
Let's take the Zulu Kingdom.
In the 1800s,
the Zulus were mighty warriors,
ruled by a fierce and brutal king
known as Shaka Zulu.
A wave of Zulu people proceeded outward
into the eastern
and central region of Africa,
where they became known
by new names, like the Ngoni
and the Ndebele of Zimbabwe.
Three dances from these regions
are known as indlamu,
isitshikitsha and ngoma.
These dances are essentially cousins.
They come from their own families,
but when you look at them,
you see the power of Shaka Zulu's Kingdom.
[Ndebele isitshkitsha dance]
[Ngoni ngoma dance]
[Zulu indlamu dance]
In the DRC, we find the Luba ethnic group,
and they have a traditional
dance called mutuashi.
This dance was used to celebrate fertility
and visually, it's liberation
of a woman's waist.
But a mutuashi dancer,
someone performing a traditional dance,
could cause a lot of controversy
to those who had adopted a more
conservative mindset from the West.
In Zambia, we find the Bemba ethnic group
who are descendants of the Luba people,
and so they share similar dances.
One of the Bemba dances
is called infunkutu,
and it’s normally seen
at a lady’s pre-marriage ceremony.
Just like the Luba people,
this dance is a celebration of a woman.
[Baluba mutuashi dance]
(Drumming and singing)
[Bemba infunkutu dance]
If we move into the eastern
part of Africa,
we find a showcase of the shoulders.
The eskista from Ethiopia supposedly
imitates the shaking of a rattlesnake,
and it closely resembles two other dances
from its neighboring countries:
the quda in Eritrea
and the kamabeka from Kenya.
These dances are performed
to different rhythms,
but their core movement remains the same.
[Bukusu kamabeka dance]
(Music)
[Ethiopia eskista dance]
[Tigrinya quda dance]
It wasn’t only migration
that separated ethnic groups
but also the artificial borders
that were drawn
by some guys from overseas.
In Ghana, Togo, Benin and Nigeria,
there were once no border distinctions
and no movement restrictions.
The Ewe people can be found
in each of these countries,
and they perform a dance
called the togo atsia,
which is danced
to the togo atsia drum pattern.
Although these people were separated,
their dance shows an endurance
of their cultural connections.
[Togo atsia dance]
(Rhythmic drumming)
Nelson Mandela once said,
"The curious beauty of African music
is that it uplifts
even as it tells a sad tale."
And I find this to be
just as true with dance.
It's restored our hope
in times of struggle.
In South Africa during apartheid,
gold miners were not allowed
to speak while they worked,
so they used their boots to create
rhythmic beats of communication,
a dance known as the gumboot dance.
And then there is zouglou.
In the '90s in Cote d'Ivoire,
university students facing
economic hardship danced
by raising their arms into the air
as if making a plea.
So we dance to celebrate
what we have overcome.
And so we find that a dance
is not just a movement,
but that movement embodies
feeling and expression
because it carries history and stories.
Today, our modern African dance
is a fusion of styles
that have come from different
traditional dances
that continues to celebrate
and appreciate our cultural heritage.
Have a look.
(Electronic dance music)
[Sangra dance]
[Legwork dance]
[Network dance]
[Zanku dance]
[Ndombolo dance]
Thank you for sharing
African dance with me today.